puso razonamiento deductivo y la
propiedad distributiva para justificar
que x + d al cuadrado es igual a x al
cuadrado más 2x y más que al cuadrado
proporciona el razonamiento para cada
paso y bueno quizás esto de usar
razonamiento deductivo suene como algo
horrendo y complicado pero en realidad
lo único que me están pidiendo es que
utilice razonamiento lógico y de hecho
este ejemplo ya lo hemos hecho antes en
algún otro vídeo así que bien lo primero
que voy a hacer es escribir este primer
cacho x + d al cuadrado
x mate
al cuadrado ahora bien yo sé que elevar
algo a una potencia entera a una
potencia entera positiva equivale
multiplicarlo por sí mismo es el número
de veces así que en realidad x + d al
cuadrado es lo mismo que
x
x más este cuadrado simplemente me dice
multiplicarlo por sí mismo dos veces
ahora bien también me dicen utiliza la
propiedad distributiva recuerdan que
dice la propiedad distributiva pues lo
que me dice es que si tengo algo de la
forma
x
ve
c
entonces esto va a ser igual
a por b
por b
más
por si lo único que estoy haciendo es en
efecto distribuir le está a cada miembro
de esta suma por eso se llama propiedad
distributiva ahora bien en este caso en
este caso no tengo a tengo x más y
multiplicando a x + d así que lo que voy
a hacer es distribuir todo esto x + d lo
voy a tratar como si x + d fuera
xd y si hago eso entonces que obtengo
obtendría
xd x x x + d
por equis ahora bien estoy asumiendo que
estos son números reales o números
enteros por lo tanto da lo mismo
escribir x + d por x que x por x + d
y ahora voy a sumarle le voy a sumar x
más deporte y por x más de nuevo estoy
usando que da exactamente lo mismo
escribir x más bien porque que ye por x
+ d bien ahora tengo esto y de nuevo
puede utilizar la propiedad distributiva
puedo distribuirle ahora está x a cada
uno de esta x y esta ley y hasta llegué
a cada uno de esta x y de estalle y
entonces podría escribir esto como
x x
x
más
x por d
bastante complicado usar los mismos
colores más
ahora distribuye el taller sobre esta
que es más de por equis
más de por qué
y por llegue de nuevo ahí simplemente
utilice la propiedad distributiva
ahora bien x x x yo sé cuánto es eso
simplemente es x al cuadrado más x
porque es lo mismo que por x x porque es
lo mismo que yo por x así que estoy
sumando dos veces x por d de modo que
esto es lo mismo que 2 veces x por d
más que porque que es cuadrado y es
justo está la expresión a la que quería
llegar es esta expresión de aquí así que
esos se refieren con razonamiento
deductivo partir de esta expresión y a
través de utilizar la lógica y las
reglas de álgebra
la propiedad distributiva en particular
llegue a esta expresión de acá así que
por lo tanto estas dos cosas son iguales